you've missed a real spectacle at Comic
Con this morning because John you went
on the streets dressed this bubblebeam
yes it was fantastic the people lost
their minds well they didn't know what
to do because they saw a bumblebee and
then many of them couldn't see me when I
revealed my identity they were like yeah
but I can't see anybody under there they
were chanting bumblebee they were down
there weren't that they were I was I was
very forceful and getting them to chant
that I think there was against their
will it was it got pretty dangerous in
the street corner for a second
how cool is it don't to come to
comic-con and do something like that
you're about to find out because I have
this boy oh do you conduct the interview
like this yes exactly it's actually
believe or not being here comic-con is
fantastic as coming from the WWE is a
Avenue in which people are extremely
passionate about who they follow this is
that same form so people from all over
the world have congregated here to just
be passionate about what they enjoy and
who they follow okay that should do it
let's try it on this is this is awesome
know what I mean have like air vents in
there Oh
she broke bump oh that was that was my
fault those ones that make them to
accident George Haley's this your first
time here it's my first time first time
I've been before a couple years ago but
I'm incredibly happy to be here now with
these comic-con virgin but this is dope
on the floor yet not yeah we're gonna go
a little bit later but I'm excited to
see all that it's it really is
unbelievable it's pretty that's pretty
cool oh this movie takes place in the
80s you two weren't born in the 1800
what's that flashback like for you the
flashback when I was a fetus yeah when I
was floating around not here as a
sparrow as a tree you know who knows it
was a great time there's a lot of good
music I mean honestly I'm not from there
but it's an era of film and stuff that
I've gone back to and to see and I love
that it gives me the same feeling that
those films gave me like this bumblebee
feature at least yeah yeah I mean it was
absolutely incredible to dive in and to
I know
just for just two seconds just lets okay
okay I'm here with you yeah I'm here
with you come on let's go know just to
immerse yourself in in that era and it
was amazing to sort of again the music
was such a huge influence on my
character and in this whole movie
obviously the Wardrobe was fun the hair
and makeup was fun to get involved with
but um can you agree great you're you're
out on the road right now so how are you
managing all this but you're still
thought it was important to get here
yeah well um I mean I wouldn't miss this
for the world
I guess I'm taking everything one step
at a time that's how I'm getting through
it but we had a show last night in
Connecticut when the voice note store
with Charlie puth and we have a show
tomorrow and in New Hampshire so I'm
here today right now all the time is it
be no pun intended
Wow can you tell us about your can you
tell us about what happens that's a
Travis what can you tell me about
bumblebee bumblebee you know I'm going I
was a child of the eighties so you know
growing up in the 80s I played with the
Transformers toys I read the comic books
I watched the cartoon and bumblebee was
always the one transformer whether the
most affinity for humanity the
disconnection with people and the great
thing about this particular story is
that we dive into why that is what what
were the kind of informed formative
experiences in his existence that led to
have this connection with people and
after that his experience with these
three lovely people we find out how he
became the bumblebee we know and love is
this how John was on the set I mean
we'll see this yeah really
like whoa no so on the daily basis
people don't know funny here John Cena
is top one of the funniest guys you've
ever seen he says the nonstop bait
machine through things also very smart
guy he knows a lot of stuff about a lot
of a lot of different things
feels good I don't like a backhanded
compliment I know so I thought I know
you know beyond with smart people it's
like whoa you saying some scientists
type stuff
hello will you sing while you're here
well I hear you sing us right now hey I
mean while you're in comic-con we sing
for the fans we do anything oh gosh
musical no I wasn't planning on it but
if there's a random opportunity that
presents itself I always love to might
be ready by the way John um I just want
to say I want to ask you a question
that's cool okay all right um how
physical do you get in this role give
them a demonstration just tell them yeah
okay I had some stunts yeah now some
moves but we've done that before me it's
my wheelhouse
yeah yeah tell me about something it's
it's you know the film at his core it
really is a sweet story about you know
the connection that that Charlie's
character Charlie has with bumblebee but
it's still a Transformers film that
means there's bellicose robots are
smashing into each other it's not knock
him sock and roll us there's a lot of
action within the film John gets into
someone yeah it's described a little bit
yeah I can say I can say that I can't
say that I can't I should have said that
that was John you and Nikki are working
things out is it because of that mask
look how you how you kind of patch thing
than you like you know yeah yeah this
this is the master that's gonna win her
back
is that is that how you know if that
truly is is the piece of the puzzle
that's been missing I'm just really
excited what this circle back and bring
us and circle back to my Wahlberg's
character some of the other care
bumblebee was almost designed to be a
self-contained film so you can watch
this movie not knowing anything about
the Transformers franchise or characters
at the same time it's layered with a lot
of different things that fans of the
franchise in the animated series will
love they'll immediately respond to even
if you're you're you know on your random
person coming to the theater they
wouldn't know it wouldn't matter but you
it's a different layer of experience for
for someone who's familiar with the
franchise and any of the other
transformers will we see anybody else
wait a minute yeah there's there's a
handful of transport it's a smaller cast
so we can focus on their characters and
their personalities more but there are
some nice little Easter eggs there's
some nice little cameos
okay all right I just wish you'd wear
that 24/7 I think I get last to the end
of this interview you've got to go you
got to go over there take a picture yeah
are we going to take a picture with that
[Music]